- Welcome and hello, everyone.
My name is Mira Debs and I
am the Executive Director
of Yale's Education Studies program.
We're so glad that you're here.
The Yale Education Studies program
is an interdisciplinary
community that empowers students
and researchers to critically examine
and collectively reshape
the education landscape
through research, policy and practice.
In our conversation this
evening, over the next hour,
we're gonna focus on the
role of student activism
and the media in addressing
educational injustice
and specifically, the
enduring school segregation
in New York City.
The nation's largest school district,
home to 1.1 million students.
New York City has an elaborate
school choice system,
primarily for middle
and high school students
with a lot of schools that
have screened admissions
where student test scores,
student grades, GPAs, attendance,
sometimes, interviews and portfolios
are all factored into
admissions decisions.
There also is a gifted
and talented program.
And there's a test for that starting
when students are four years old.
So as a result of these screens,
an enduring problem in New York City
is that the most elite
schools are disproportionately
White and Asian in a district
that is majority black
and LatinX students.
And so as you'll learn this evening,
students have been
fighting for over 50 years
to integrate New York City schools.
In 1964, the largest
civil rights demonstration
during the civil rights movement,
464,000 students participated
in a walkout protesting
the segregated schools
of New York City.
And in the last decade, the
topic of school integration
with the help of student
activists from organizations
including Teens Take Charge
and Integrate New York
City have been integral
in pushing this issue back
to the center of the education agenda.
The students have also focused
not only on integration
but educational self-determination
and empowering students
to determine alongside
with their communities,
an equitable future.
You may be wondering why focus
on school integration right now?
We're in the middle of a pandemic.
Many schools are closed,
students are out of school.
So why this issue right now?
As I've heard repeatedly
from students and parents,
and I'm currently doing research
with Molly Makris and Elise
Castillo on this topic,
this issue is only more urgent right now.
The pandemic has made
inequality between neighborhoods
and between communities and
schools even more apparent.
There is no going back
to the way things were.
And in the last two months,
there has been some significant progress
in terms of announcements from the mayor
and the school's chancellor
regarding middle school screens,
some high school admissions
and it changed to the
gifted and talented test.
So there's momentum and
change happening right now
even in the middle of a pandemic.
A few notes on logistics
before we get started.
Our panel discussion is
gonna run about 35 minutes
and then we will have time for questions.
And you can submit a question at any time
via the Q&A tab in the
bottom of your screen.
And it is now my honor to pass
the baton to our moderator,
Sarah Medina Camiscoli.
Sarah is a third year law student at Yale.
She's a lecture in the
Education Studies program.
And she's also one of the adult founders
of Integrate New York City.
And for that reason, Sarah
is a living representation
of the nexus of research
policy and practice
which is core to the ed studies program.
So thank you so much, Sarah.
- Yeah, thank you, Mira.
Hey, all, this is such a gift
to be with you all today.
I'd like to kick us off as we tend to do
in the youth organizing space
with setting some intentions.
And so the intentions
I've set to for today
and gotten consent from our panelists for,
are one, to create an
intergenerational discussion
on self-determined movement,
building and resistance
for integration and structural equity.
So what does that mean
for you in the audience
and what does that mean for our panelists?
It means that I ask that you listen deeply
and write questions, comments, ideas,
when you feel animated or curious.
This work does not move without
interaction and exchange.
The second is to build a
robust, diverse network
of students, organizers,
academics, and researchers
who elevates students
and families to build
authentic integration
and anti-racist education
as they see it so that
all people may thrive.
To that end, I ask that you
consider the unique strengths
of each person here.
The school integration
movement cannot happen
without each person here.
And consider the ways that
you might provide resources,
networks, expertise to
support anyone here.
And at the end, when we
ask you to take action,
I ask that you do it in
exchange for the hour
that folks here have given
with their wisdom and their story.
So to kick it off,
I would love for our panelists
to introduce themselves.
Name, PGP, the organization you
are representing here today,
your role in it, and how
did you start working
in the school integration space?
And I'll popcorn into someone
as you tend to do in the organizing space
and have them popcorn to someone else.
Aneth, I will ask you
to kick it off for us.
- Hey, y'all.
My name's Aneth.
My pronouns are she, her, hers.
I'm part of IntegrateNYC.
My role is co-founding director
and the way I got started,
I've actually been working
with IntegrateNYC for five years now.
And I got involved
through a school exchange
that my school did with Bronx Letters.
Yeah, I'll popcorn it to Obrian.
- Hey, everybody. My name's Obrian.
Pronouns, he, him and his.
I'm a director and youth
coach with IntegrateNYC.
And I got involved
three years ago in 2018.
When I attended a rally
for the fair play coalition
regarding sports equity.
And I've been involved
with the work ever since.
And I'll popcorn it to Alex.
- Hi, everybody.
My name's Alex Rodriguez.
My pronouns are open.
And I guess you can say my role
in Teen Takes Charge is an
alumni coach, and my involvement
with youth activism is
quite an expansive story
but I guess most simply
put, it all started
in a conversation with my
really good friend, Sukan Jara
in Forever 21 of all places.
And we just started kicking it off
and talking about our
experiences in school.
And then next thing you know,
I'm in a wonderful organizing space
with other youth of color.
And then I'll pass it on to Ayana.
- Hi, my name is Ayana Smith.
My pronouns are she, her, hers.
I'm like Alex, like graduated
out of Teens Take Charge.
So I'm kinda serving
as an alumni coach now.
I think my story with school integration
and just education justice work begins
probably in my ninth grade when I learned
about the achievement gap.
I was really motivated to
act and do something about it
but I didn't have the
platform at the time.
And then one day, one of
my close friends said,
hey, you should join Teens Take Charge.
It seems like something
you'd be interested in.
And from, there I've been
involved in the organization
and doing a ton of ed justice work.
- Oh, I'm next.
It's a real pleasure to have a chance
to speak with all of you this evening.
I'm Matt Delmont, professor of
history at Dartmouth College.
I guess my involvement
with school integration
began as an observer involved
in an open enrollment program
in Minneapolis in 1980s
when I was in elementary school.
As a researcher, I'm
interested in the history
of civil rights and always
have been interested
in how our schools became segregated
and how people fought against that.
So I've done work on I Philadelphia,
New York City, Boston, Chicago.
It's a real pleasure to have
a chance to make connections
between history and the present day
on the panel this evening.
Back to you, Sarah.
- Thanks, Matt.
So we have incredible
blessing of a panel here today
and I'm really excited to get into things.
What I'm curious about
is why our audience hasn't asked questions
such as where is this amazing Forever 21,
where all of these student
organizers begin their careers
or what is the school exchange?
Again, given the virtual
world that we're in,
we're gonna rely on folks
to really have active question-making.
So feel free to start
popping those questions in.
Okay, so the first couple of
questions on things, folks
for all the questions that are coming in.
Professor Debs is gonna
be moderating them.
The first question is for Mr. Delmont.
Take us back to the New York City activism
that you cover in your
book, Why Busing Failed.
What were the demonstrations of students
and parents and how were
they covered by the media?
- Thanks, Sarah for that question.
So as professor Debs mentioned,
there was a massive
school boycott in 1964.
The largest protest in the
history of civil rights.
460,000 students stay out of school
to protest a school
starvation in New York City.
And what's interesting about the story
in New York is it really had been going on
for a whole decade prior to that.
So usually when we were
taught about the history
of school segregation
and school integration,
it's usually a southern
story, but the story
of New York City is really
a parallel story to that,
to the southern story.
So in the early 1950s, Ella Baker,
the famous civil rights
organizer is the president
of the New York branch of the NAACP.
And she's working with Kenneth Clark,
the famous psychologist
to organize parents
and civic leaders to really protest
to kind of extreme inequality
they see in the city's public schools.
They know that black and LatinX students
are going to schools
that are under-resourced.
They know that a lot of these
textbooks in those schools
have racist texts and racist images.
And they want the students
be able to go to schools
that have equal resources
and are equitable.
That happens even before
the Brown vs Board decision.
When Brown vs Board is decided
by the Supreme Court in 1954,
activists in New York say, why not here?
The decision is focused
on southern schools
but they see, they look all
around and they see that schools
in New York are equally
segregated and they demand action.
They demand action
through public protests,
through editorials and through statements
at school board meetings.
'Cause they're trying to bring
this issue into the public.
For a lot of folks in
New York at that time,
they just didn't believe
that school segregation,
educational inequality
could be issues in New York.
They thought this is a
liberal progressive place.
These kind of issues
only happen in the south.
They can actually happen in New York City.
So they're trying to push out in the open.
In 1957, the same year
as the Little Rock school
integration crisis,
there's a group of mothers in
New York who filed a lawsuit
against the school board to
protest educational inequality.
And they hold their children
out of school for months in protest.
This is a boycott that risked jail time.
And the black press dubbed
them the Harlem Nine.
So to play on the Little Rock Nine.
So this is going on at the exact same time
what's going on in the south.
These protests continue and escalate
in the late 1950s, early 1960s.
Reverend Milton Galamison
and then a woman named Annie Stein.
We had a group called the
Parents' Workshop for Equality.
And they threatened as early
as 1960 a large-scale boycott
because they're just
calling on the school board
to do something meaningful to
address school segregation.
Over this entire period from 1954 to 1964,
the school board makes
only really small changes.
So they might move a few hundred students
from an overcrowded school in the Bronx
to a bus crowded school in Queens.
But mostly, the school
board drags their feet.
They refuse to acknowledge
that school segregations are a real issue.
They refuse to take any meaningful steps.
And even those small scale changes are met
with intense resistance
from white parents.
Who frankly, wanna
maintain the status quo.
They wanna maintain racial
segregation in the schools.
So by February, 1964,
when this massive school
boycott takes place,
civil rights activists have
been fighting the school board
for more than a decade
and they have a little to show for it.
So they're exhausted, they're
frustrated and they demanded
this is the time that action's
finally gonna take place.
That boycott itself brings
together a coalition
of different groups,
both kind of more moderate
groups, more militant groups.
It's something that
doesn't really get taught
in the same way in our textbooks,
because the media at the time,
particularly the White media,
seems like the New York Times
disregards that kind of protest.
They call it a violent active
adult-encouraged truancy.
And so it's not treated with the same
kind of sense of urgency
as a civil rights protests
going on in Montgomery,
Selma and Little Rock
at the same time.
And so I think for me, what's important
about that story about school integration
and the civil rights
activism in New York City
is that parents, students
were intensely organized.
And they're trying to
fight to make this an issue
that would be acknowledged,
but the school board
at every turn, tried to push back
and maintain the status
quo of segregation.
- Thanks, Matt.
I have another question here.
And then folks, I'm
gonna be turning it over
to our student activists here
on the panel to ask any
follow up questions.
And if not, I'll probably jump in
to some questions that
I'm seeing in the chat.
But what did people understand the story
to be about desegregation?
And what would you say
is the most important
misunderstanding that you
wanted to disrupt in your book?
- Yeah, one of the
things that's fascinating
to me about this history in the north
is there's a sense that it was optional.
So sometimes, people will
talk about the history
of segregation in the north
and say it was de facto.
That it was somehow by
customer, by market forces.
And this is segregation,
school segregation
in places like New York, Chicago, Boston,
it was intentional.
The school boards drew zoning lines
in ways that would
purposely create schools
that were predominantly Latino,
predominantly white,
predominantly African-American.
But they did it in such a
way that they kind of hid
the racist intent of it, which
made it very, very difficult
for activists to bring
these cases into court
and to actually get justice and to finally
get some actual
integration in the schools.
So, one thing I tried to show in the book
was that these protests
over school desegregation,
they really needed to,
when we think about them
in the north, we need to think about them
with the same sense of moral urgency
as we tend to think about
school segregation in the south.
That over the years, the
debate has really been switched
in such a way that all
of the focus becomes
on the perspectives and
desires of white parents.
Whereas when we're talking
about school integration,
what we should be
focusing on is the rights
and educational outcomes for
black and LatinX students.
- Thanks, Matt.
Do any of our student activists
here have any questions?
I feel like Matt in particular,
brought up some of the untold
stories of mostly black
and Puerto Rican student
organizers in New York City.
Anyone wanna ask any questions?
I had a question Matt, that
I wanted to follow up on,
why do you feel like it's
often such an untold story
that the largest civil
rights demonstration
was a half million black
and Puerto Rican students in New York?
What do you think is driving that story
not being covered and not
being made front and center
at the time when it happened and today?
Because I'm sure a lot
of people on this call
are like, wait a minute,
let me fact check that.
The largest civil rights demonstration
was Black and Puerto Rican
students in New York City?
I don't think that's right.
- Yeah, and the reason didn't
get attention at the time.
And the reason it hasn't
gotten much attention
until recently is that
it's a more uncomfortable
and difficult story for a lot of people,
particularly folks in
the north to reckon with.
What I mean by that is it was
easier for white folks in 1964
whether that's the parents,
the school board or media
to point to places in the south and say,
bad things that are
happening in the south.
That's where racism exists.
It exists down in Montgomery
and down in Selma.
It can't possibly exist in New York.
That's to actually
think about the history.
Honestly, it forces people to reckon
with the privilege they have
in their own neighborhoods
in terms of housing, in terms of schools
and it actually forces
them to give up something.
So one of the things
that Martin Luther King
would always say when he came
to speak in New York City
and other places in New
York was that white liberals
and white moderates had to
actually live up to their ideals.
It wasn't enough to be
liberal when we're talking
about race just in the south,
you had to be a liberal and actually came
to your own neighborhood,
into your own backyard.
I mean, I think that was true in the 60s,
I think it's true today.
It's hard.
There's a willful ignorance
that a lot of people
would like to have about the realities
of racism in our country.
I think that's particularly true
in places that people want to think of
as being somehow more
progressive or more liberal.
It allows them to not deal
with the actual reality
of how race is structured in our country.
- I actually have one
follow-up question for you
and then I'm gonna pass it
along to the folks here.
I heard you say asking folks to be liberal
in their own neighborhoods.
It almost sounds to me
like the word liberal and anti-racist
are being interchangeable
in that statement.
Could you maybe elaborate
a little bit more for me
around how you understand conservativism
versus liberalism in this conversation?
And when they do and don't become words
that can be replaced with one another?
- Sure, that's a big question.
So thinking about the
time period I'm studying,
the circle time period.
Conservatives would have
been more directly outspoken
and say, I'm thinking of
folks like Barry Goldwater,
the Senator from Arizona
who was explicitly opposed
to the Civil Rights Act.
He thought it was unconstitutional.
He didn't think that the
government had a role to play
in promoting integration.
So I think conservatives
in that time period
were more vocal in their opposition.
Liberals, white liberals
in this case had a position
where they would say they're in favor
of integration generally,
but when push came to shove,
they did everything they could
to not actually integrate
their own neighborhoods
and their own schools.
And so I think that's a sort
of a structuring reality
about how white liberalism
has functioned in our country
is that it's liberal in
sort of general strokes,
but not actually in
practice when actually comes
to things that directly
impact people's lives.
The term anti-racist
didn't exist in the 60s.
But I think part of what
King was calling for
was people to be proactive,
to take the actions
that would follow up on their ideals.
And so I think to transpose
it into the present,
I think the kind of
things we see taking place
in New York City right now,
it doesn't do much good to say
you're in favor of educational equality
if you're not actually going
to support, proactively support
the policies and the steps
that are gonna produce
those outcomes on the ground.
- Thanks so much, folks.
I'm gonna move to our Integrated NYC
and Teens Take Charge folks.
But wanna give folks here an opportunity
to possibly ask any questions,
any follow up to Matt.
Okay.
I also just wanna shout out.
I see a lot of folks in the
chat from integrated schools.
Such a blessing to be with you all today.
So I wanna first start off,
Matt talks a lot in his book about busing
and how busing becomes the
thing that people talk about
is segregation and is the
issue around integration.
And that's the real issue and
why it's remained segregated.
I'm wondering if we could start maybe
with IntegrateNYC first and
talking about in 2014 and 2015,
when y'all first started, what
was the busing of the time?
What was the thing that people
told you integration was?
And what were the ways
that you had to really
push against that to create the five Rs?
- I think busing was the thing for us.
Like maybe not busing busing,
but just like the movement of bodies.
And maybe like enrollment
was only talked about
when we first started
and the quick solution
was sort of seen as,
well, if we just make the
schools look different,
that will solve the problem
or if we make them look desegregated,
that will solve the problem.
But I don't think the
people making this policy,
it's not I don't think,
I know that the people making
this policy didn't think
about what students felt and
experienced every single day
because us students, it
was so obvious for us
to see that enrollment
wasn't the only issue
and enrollment wasn't
the only solution either.
And so that's why when we
began our youth councils
and meeting with students
all across the five boroughs,
we created the five Rs.
We will be first like talked
about our experiences.
And I saw somebody asked like
what a school exchange is.
And for us, it's basically
like when you buddy up
with someone in the other school,
you have a group of students
kind of buddying each other up
and you take each other through
your day in your school.
And for all of us, that community
and relationship work was really important
because it allowed us to
see each other's experience
and then have similar conversations
with other students from
other schools around the city.
And that's kind of how we came
about our Five R platform,
which is race in enrollment.
So yes, let's address race in enrollment
and actually name like race.
And what are other
factors that we are taking
into account when enrolling students?
Because that shouldn't be the only thing.
And like, how do we use those factors
to benefit students rather
than like penalize them
for stuff that has
happened in their lives.
We have resources which talks
about how resources are are allocated
inequitably across like schools.
Some schools get so many sports scenes,
other schools get to zero.
Some schools get three science labs,
others get broken lab equipment.
And we talk about
representation, which talks about
how, which really addresses
a lot of our teachers
and a lot of the people
who are teaching us stuff
and like in front of
the classroom are white
and don't look like most
Black and Brown students.
And don't really, are not able to identify
and connect with them in that way.
So how are we addressing
that issue as well.
We talk about relationships,
which is like, okay,
once we're all in the building
and we're in a diversified
space, what does that mean?
How do we build relationships together?
Like how, we're not just
gonna ignore all the tension
and the history of
trauma that our families,
our individual families
and our individual
bodies have gone through.
And we also have
restorative justice which,
so lost, (indistinct).
(laughs), these Five Rs.
I also wanna invite Obrian
if you wanna add anything
in those Rs.
Our last R is restorative justice,
which deals with the
schooler prism pipeline
which shows that a lot of our students
and especially our
Black and Brown students
are being locked up and
are being isolated from,
may perhaps the only
institution that could give them
any kind of stability.
And so, what does restorative
justice look like?
And how do we really build a community
where we can learn from our mistakes
and not punish students,
especially our Black and Brown students.
- Thanks so much, Aneth.
I'd love to hear a little
bit from Teens Take Charge
about the way that you've disrupted media
and the way that you've used new media,
new ways to address media,
the way that the podcast has done that
and really shifted the
way that young people
are like Matt was saying, push to the side
in the narrative about integration.
What are the innovative ways
that you've really transformed
how students are centered
in mainstream media?
- Yeah, I think Matt brings up
a really good point when
talking about how the north
was kind of seen as this like holy grail.
And to this day, it's like very much.
We see a lot of, dare I
say, like neocolonization
of terms like progressive
and democrat or liberal.
And what we find is a lot of parents,
especially parents were
opposed to integration
kind of use these as almost
shields to protect them
from their own racist tendencies
when talking about education.
And so what Teens Take Charge
has been doing a lot of,
it's trying to infiltrate as
much as the media as possible
to kind of make these problems known.
It's been swept under the rug
for literally decades, right?
And we know that if there's
anything that our generation
can do, is completely
infiltrate the media.
And so, we made sure to
center as much student voices
as possible because
those are undisputable,
at least I'd hope to be.
And so with the podcast,
we're talking about
the in-person experiences
that different students have
at different underfunded
institutions and things like that.
That's one way.
We've been so fortunate to have plenty,
like a couple of documentaries
about student experiences
and their different
intersectional experiences
about living in a extremely
segregated school system.
But also just like things
like Instagram and Twitter,
that has also been really
fundamental at educating
our followers and reaching
all over the place
because I mean, it's everywhere.
How can we engage with our audience
in a more personal level?
And when we do these
types of media campaigns,
hashtags and things like that as well.
- Yeah, wow.
Every time I hear what the
media, I just get really excited.
As in take charges,
former co-director for us
because that was my life from
the year that I was involved
in an organization before graduating.
And I feel like in my
experience, adding on
to what Alex said, definitely the media
has been prevalent in
steering the conversation
and bringing light to it.
But I feel like at least when
I published my first op ed,
it was a really like personal experience.
I remember walking into school
the next day and my principal
stopping me in the hallway
and asking me about
school integration in my
work and like praising my,
and she shared it with other teachers
and students within the school.
And that started a school-wide discussion
about school integration
for around a week or so.
Like every time I publish something,
it was featured in something.
Students and teachers together,
we kind of just learned from
each other's experiences
when we had the free
time to engage in that.
So storytelling is definitely a big part
of youth organizing
around school integration.
And it really does start conversations
and allows people to like
change the narratives
and come together and just
create a new understanding
and vision for education
in the future, so, yeah.
- Thank you so much.
I have a conversation.
I've appreciated a couple
of comments in the chat
because oftentimes, what
people are looking at
is what's in the media
but not knowing about what's
actually in the movement
and the way that we have
to work to heal each other
and support each other.
And so I wanted to get more
on a personal level to
really give folks here,
this is a form of media arguably, right?
The opportunity to just really appreciate
what the folks here are doing
and the many lonely challenging moments
outside of the exciting meetings
or the inspiring time at Forever 21.
There's a lot of lonely
times when you wonder,
do I wanna take that risk?
Do I wanna deal with
people on the internet
making racial slurs at me?
Do I wanna deal with my classmates
or parents putting me down?
And so I'd like to ask
this first question.
It comes from one of
our students who said,
"What is a moment that
you felt segregation
in your body that you
actually felt the experience?
What did it feel like?
Where were you and would you be willing
to share a little bit
with the group here?"
- I can go first.
So I went to a specialized high school.
I went to Brooklyn Technical High School.
And you know, that school is like,
"The most diverse
specialized high school."
But the representation
for students like myself
as an Afro-Latino is
like almost zero to none.
So I think that it's common at least,
for Black students, for LatinX students
to gather in different
meetings and different spaces.
So for instance, there's like the BSU,
which is the Black Student Union.
As well as ASPIRA, which is this club
that's "An investment in
Latino youth and LatinX youth."
And I think that it's a very alienating,
it's a very like lonely space to navigate
especially in a specialized high school
with more than like 6,000 plus students.
And where you only see
a very small percentage
of that 6,000 student mass
being students that look like you.
to add onto that, I
don't think I can recall
or I can count with the fingers on my hand
how many teachers I've had
that were teachers of color,
were teachers that looked like me.
And all of that speaks to the different Rs
and the different platforms
that we work with at IntegrateNYC.
But I feel like, I also had
privileges when it came to that.
So I went to a New York City
specialized high school.
So I had access to all the different APs.
I had access to 40 plus sports teams.
I had access to a whole
freaking plane flight navigator
on like in the school building.
And to know that there's students
that don't even have a cafeteria to sit
and have lunch at, there are students
that don't have any
access to sports scenes,
there are students that, you know,
there's houseless students,
there's students in
the foster care system.
And like there's people that are coming
from all these different backgrounds
and to step into a building
where you're already not really welcomed,
you're not really represented
in the curriculum.
I feel like it's something
that we all deal with.
But for me personally, it's like
I go to Howard University now
where I have Black educators
and I learn about my history
and about black history
but I would have never done that
if it would have been in the New York City
public school system
I would have never had access
to these types of things.
And I never really had people
that looked like me around me.
So I was always kind of on my own.
And that's like, there's
several different instances.
I can just name one where I just felt
the segregation present, but it's real
and it exists and I was going through that
and I didn't realize that
I was going through that
at the time until I started
working with IntegrateNYC.
- Obrian, thanks so much for sharing that.
I really heard in his sharing
about the experience of loneliness
and the experience of
just really feeling torn
between trying to get an opportunity
and trying to support your community.
And I'm wondering if anyone else here
on the panel has felt things
like loneliness or feeling torn?
Are there other feelings
that are present for you
as young people who have
lived through segregation
and lived through this largest
segregated school system
in the United States?
- Yeah, I mean, like Obrian was sharing,
it's almost hard to kind of
just pinpoint one experience
because I think we grow
up in these school systems
and we kinda get so used to being
in these very kind of
microcosmic environments
that you don't really
necessarily recognize
hey, I'm living in a
segregated school system.
Especially if what you're
learning in school,
in history always puts away the focus
from New York City and your
experiences onto the south.
It almost serves as kind of
like this crazy scapegoat
that prevents often, the white
history teachers from looking
into themselves in way that
they also segregate students
within their own classrooms.
And I guess one thing that I can share
is I think my school,
I went to predominantly
Black and Brown (indistinct)
school in Brooklyn.
And one of the things
that my school tried to do
to give access to a lot of resources
to its students is kind of send them
on enrichment programs
outside of the school.
So kind of going to
different parts of the city
and engaging in different
types of activities
and extracurriculars that the school
just couldn't offer in-house.
And a lot of the times,
they would send the students
into very, very white and wealthy spaces.
And one that comes to
mind is a model congress
that I went to around the 10th grade.
And it was probably one of
the most jarring experiences
that I've ever really had
because I didn't really know
there were white students
in New York City for a really long time.
Because I grew up in the little Caribbean.
I went to Black and Brown
schools pretty much all my life.
And so to then go to a model congress,
which is very like a showboaty type thing,
and then to see that like
out of like, I don't know,
200, 300 students, my school's
the only delegation composed
of entirely students of color.
It was the most jarring thing to ever see.
And I was often the only person of color
within just a room.
And that is when I started to get hit
with all these classic experiences.
I'm sure a lot of people here would relate
to the microaggressions.
Even incidents of just overt racism.
Very gatekeeper, ask language
and things like that.
And so I think from
there on now, I started
to become way more cognizant
of just all the experiences.
It kind of started to hit me
like a lot at the same time.
And it took me some time to also just heal
from that trauma that I had to endure
in conferences like
that from there on out.
- Yeah, I think it's a
really interesting question.
I think like we're constantly living
in a segregated society, right?
So even if some of us have
graduated high school,
I think all of us have,
we still stepped into,
most of us are like
stepping into segregated
higher education institutions.
And even outside education institutions,
we do live in a segregated space I guess.
And it is challenging.
I feel like throughout the time,
and throughout our work, we've gained
the language to maybe tell our story
and be like, okay, this is happening,
and like kinda name that.
And that has in itself, been hard
like learning how to name your story
and how to tell it it's a real process.
And I think, we also feel like
a lot of imposter syndrome,
even in our organizing
spaces, I feel like maybe
that's the loneliest I've ever felt.
When imposter syndrome
kind of starts creeping in.
And there's not like one
time that had happened
and then that's it.
I feel like it has
happened throughout my life
where you feel like
because of who you are,
you don't belong in that space.
Or you look around you or
in my particular experience,
I was always how they say cherry picked
to be in AP classes or honors classes.
And it was always like
a jarring experience
to look around you and
see only one other person
or two other people that look like you.
And I feel like even an organizing.
I remember when we first
started out IntegrateNYC,
we did this video project type of thing.
And I started this work with
my white peer who also went
to the same school as I did.
And I remember we were both in the video.
And then when we came out of that,
we were standing together,
but people were going up to her
and asking her questions
about what segregation means
and what integration mean
and what integrating we see is about.
And so, I feel like it's really,
it can be like we'll need to see
how maybe people perceive you.
I don't know about lonely,
but it's just exhausting, you know?
And like, although we're
activists and we're organizers,
we can't constantly be
having the energy to have
to stop and have a
conversation with someone
and try to change their whole perspective.
So I think like learning
how to build our boundaries,
and like me, learning how
to build my boundaries
has been really important in not having
those learning moments or
like imposter syndrome moments
and knowing that I don't
have to be perfect.
And also that my community's here with me.
- I'm still trying to formulate a response
to that question because definitely
a lot process and think about.
And I feel like in my
organizing experience,
I didn't necessarily feel loneliness.
Throughout my entire K
through 12 experience,
I've only really existed in spaces
that were predominantly
Black and LatinX students.
So I definitely didn't feel
that sense of isolation
in terms of my race or ethnicity
but I feel like a lot of what
I had to experience related
to organizing was definitely unpacking
things like internalized
racism, internalized sexism
and other traumas that come
with being a member of a BIPOC group.
And that in itself has been
extremely uncomfortable.
And I remember when I first
started, Teens Take Charge
was often questioned my
commitment and questioning
whether or not this was a
mission that I could get behind.
But I realized that that process mostly
is about kind of self-exploration
and self-discovery.
And it also definitely
connected to feelings
of fear whenever I did publish things
or spoken public to people.
Because once you say something
where it's out in the world,
you can't necessarily take that back.
So like feeling, having
to feel like affirmed
and competent in what I was saying
and believing in myself in terms of that.
But yeah, sorry if the
response was unclear,
I'm still trying to think about it.
- I feel like that was so
powerful, what you just said.
Especially the piece about
not being able to take it back
and taking that risk every time.
So thank you for taking the
risk again here on this panel.
I appreciate you.
Matt, I was wondering
as these incredible
organizers were speaking,
what stood out to you the most?
And what's a question you have for them
or something that you think is
just really worth elevating?
Because I feel like they said so much
and I'd love to hear just
what's going on for you.
- I mean, there's a dozen things.
I mean, one of the first
ones is just thinking
about how this doesn't
stop after high school.
We're seeing all of you are in college.
And I don't know where everyone's
probably mostly a
primary way institutions.
I'm at Dartmouth.
I'm a full professor and encountered a lot
of the same things that
you all are describing.
And Aneth, what you're talking about,
sort of feeling like you're cherry pick
to sort of be one of
the handful of people.
That's verbatim the experience
of most faculty of color
at these institutions now.
And I think when you sort of think
about what it means to
sort of the live reality
of segregation means that
you're constantly encountering
people who are discovering
these things anew
for the first time.
I think that's part of
the summer of 2020, right?
For a lot of people, it
was eye opening experience
about sort of depths of racism,
depths of police brutality.
And for a lot of communities color,
it was another summer.
And so I think that's
striking me the importance
of kind of trying to teach
and bring these stories to the fore.
The thing I would love
to know more from you all
is there's a question in
the chat from Alex Apsahi.
Tell me what teachers can do
to support teen activists.
So in UIC, a lot of my own
students of color here on campus.
So could you reflect on,
first, think about
yourself as a high school,
thing about yourselves now in college.
What does it mean for when
you're working with teachers?
What would you like to see teachers do
in the classroom support to you,
either in terms of how
they're structuring lessons,
of teaching about
history is what histories
would have helped you
to know when you were
in junior high in high school.
Or just in terms of
structuring conversations
and making space for centering your voices
and your experiences.
I would love to learn
from you as an educator.
- I guess I can go.
I mean, that's a loaded question.
I guess, kind of one of
the best things that I have
when I was organizing in high school,
there were definitely people in my school
that were not in full support
of everything that I was doing
with my colleagues at Teens
Take Charge and IntegrateNYC.
And that was probably one of
the most mentally taxing things
to have to go through when you
are kind of in the authority
of somebody else who
clearly is not in support
which was also just very
jarring for me to see
because like a lot of people mentioned,
you're often in these primarily
Black and Brown schools
where teachers who are bearing
the dominant identities.
And I guess the biggest thing
that teachers did for me
that were supporting me
were just settling time
to talk and just talk through emotions,
things that you're feeling,
checking in on you.
And I think of course being lenient
on like certain types of things
or your also emotional capacity
and just passing on their wisdom as well.
especially teachers of
color who have to also deal
with people who are above them
in a sense with their jobs
but also have to manage their
own emotional kind of states
when they're working in
institutions like this.
And I guess the biggest
kind of thing that I can say
is just also be open to learn.
I think a lot of places
that I have been a student
and there's almost this kind
of teacher-student dynamic,
where the teacher feels
like they just have
to inculcate everything
they know into the student
and you miss a lot of value
in the student's experience.
I think learning should
be a two-way street.
The teacher should also be the student
and the student should
also be the teacher.
And honoring that you don't have to relate
to every single experience
your student has.
And so kind of guiding that as well.
- Thanks so much.
I know that we're gonna now open it up
to our audience here.
'Cause we have about hopefully,
like a hundred students,
parents, organizers
in the audience whose voices
we'd love to hear as well.
And so I'd love to elevate
some of their questions here.
I believe, okay.
We have a question here,
which is specifically looking
at white parents and school districts.
I know that there's an
organization represented here.
That's working to also
organize white parents.
And I know Matt's book speaks specifically
about the resistance of white parents
and y'all haven't really talked
about the microaggressions
that you've experienced.
What are some actions that
you think white parents
and white students can take
as allies in this work?
If you were to talk about
what allyship looks like
and if allyship isn't enough,
what being a co-conspirator it looks like.
- I think this is also a
really interesting question.
I think, I was gonna say this
with the teacher questions
who I think the first,
most important thing to do is to listen.
We can sit here and tell
y'all our experiences
and what our teachers might have done
or what are white allies might have done
but this comes from our community.
So I think first thing is to really listen
to what your community is saying
and to what your young people are saying.
Or the young people in your spaces.
And then like, sort of be brave with that.
Especially if you hold like a position
where you have institutional power
or any type of power where
people are listening to you
because a lot of the times,
administration is not
listening to students.
So I think it's really
important to be brave
with young people.
A lot of time, I hear that young people
are like organizers
because they're not afraid
because we don't have anything to lose,
but I think we're like,
we fight really hard because
we have everything to lose.
So when I think like being brave with us.
Not just listening to us and
like making a space for us.
I think something that one of my teachers
in my school did and what
I wish the white parents
and the white students in my school
would have done is take, have
meetings with my principal.
I think one of the, like, yeah.
So my teacher had like,
we all had a meeting with our principal.
It was like the respects for
all coalition in my school
and my teacher, she's Ecuadorian like me.
And she was the first
Ecuadorian and Latina teacher
that I ever had in my educational career.
And she just, she was brave for us.
We said all of these things are missing
and she voiced that to
us, to our principal.
And like our principals didn't
even really have the words,
he made excuses but that taking a stance
is really important.
And taking up that space
that you know you can take up
to have a conversation that
we're saying needs to happen
is really important as
sort of like taking,
like giving back power to you
know it doesn't belong to you.
Give back the power to the young people.
- Yeah, I definitely wanna
underscore and that's point
about amplifying the
work that already exists
and work being done by primary
stakeholders of the issue.
And I think also it's really
important to make a distinction
between allyship and then
performative allyship.
And I personally define
performative allyship
as people who kind of just engage
within social justice work
just for popularity or likes on Instagram.
And I guess to combat that
is definitely making
sure your interactions
within organizing spaces are
meaningful and intentional.
And you're kinda just really
engaged in what's happening
and also committing and
kind of just being there
at your full capacity at all times.
So and wants to elaborate on that.
- Thanks, Ayana.
This is a question for
Matt from the audience.
Could you please situate the
youth of color in the 1960s?
Did they form independent
and distinct groups
in this movement, even if
in partnerships with adults?
- Yes, so, and there's multiple
different forms organizing,
some kinda more clearly codified.
So youth councils with the NAACP
and with other organizations.
And then there were more
kind of informal organizing
that would happen at the high school level
where people just kind of recognize
that this was something that was,
that they wanted to take action on.
So it happened both sort
of just inter within youth
and then more kind of intergenerational
with parents as well.
Sometimes organized around churches
and other civic organizations.
I think the important thing
was that it was consistent
ongoing organization
from young people.
It was creative, it was relentless.
Like a lot of the organizing today.
And it was widespread across the city.
So you don't get 460,000 students
stay out of school without a
huge amount of coordination.
And without people really
dedicated themselves to that work.
So I think that those
are kinda connections
between then and now.
- You know, I'd also
like to pop in here too
and add that what we
understand to be integration
when we look retrospects,
perspectively back.
And I'm not saying we don't wanna focus
just on the movement of bodies, right?
So something that we did
the five point platform
on real integration,
I'm sure anyone here who's
seen a pamphlet or wrote a book
about the Black Panthers
or the Young Lords
knows about a multipoint
platform by youth of color.
We studied the Young Lords platforms.
We study the Black Panthers
when we were doing the Five R.
And so, I just wanna name that
because when our students
were reclaiming integration
and reclaiming what real integration was,
it wasn't that they were making that up.
They were integrating youth movements
over the course of time.
And the Young Lords and the Black Panthers
have been historically criminalized
and situated as, I think not situated
in the same way as integration organizers,
situated as some sort
of controversial groups
and something that we've
tried to make very clear
is that the Black Panthers
and the Young Lords are as controversial
as folks who were organizing
for traditional forms of integration.
There are benefits and disadvantages
to all of the different platforms.
And so that's been something
that we've been making sure to name.
I'd love to end today's panel.
We're mostly organizers
and activists here.
And so I'd love to end today's panel
with a call to action for folks.
And so I'd just love
if all our participants
could just like round themselves
and listen in and tune in
and really believe in
reciprocity in the movement.
And so each of our students
here, and hopefully,
Matt and Mira will
share one kind of action
that they think you can
take to elevate their work.
Excuse me, or to elevate
the movement for school integration.
And I'd ask each participant
to just pledge in the chat
what they're gonna do.
And so I'm gonna first hand
it over to Teens Take Charge
who has a summit this weekend.
Y'all wanna share a little bit about that?
- Yeah.
So Teens Take Charge is
planning a nationwide summit
on Saturday with, we're calling
it Activists X Academics,
which is really a
partnership between activists
in New York City, as well as
academics across the country.
And so we have people like Gary Warfield
coming up to speak with us.
We have Julianne Boyce
who is moderating a panel
with the wonderful Tiffany and Sophia.
I don't know if you've
read their work before.
And so thank you, Sarah
for putting the registration
link in the chat.
So yeah, please check it
out and feel free to look
and see if this is something
you'd be interested in.
It's completely free for youth.
And then we're asking for adults,
if you can donate whatever
you can to support
the youth activists that are
going to be on these panels.
- Thanks so much, Alex.
I'm also going to just share
a quick intro to integrate.
And then we're gonna dive
into actually a very
Yale-centered opportunity here
with one of our organizers.
But integrate on my seat,
we are always looking just
like Teens Take Charge shared,
for resources and expertise and networks
to elevate and support
our student organizers.
And this is a university
just teaming with resources.
So if you have a resource,
a network and idea,
please, I ask that you click that link
and you send us a contact.
You send us an email in our
contact and share it with us.
It takes out 30 seconds, but
could really make a difference.
But now, this is a really
exciting opportunity.
I'm gonna hand it over to Aneth and Obrian
who are gonna elevate one
of our youth organizers
who's actually a student here at Yale
who's building out a university network
to bring grassroots movements
to the university space.
Just like Matt said, is so needed.
So Aneth, Obrian, you
wanna share a little bit
about that opportunity?
- Yeah, for sure.
Well, it's currently in the
works is called Integrate U,
which is being spearheaded
by Joaquin Sotto.
He's a currently a first
year student here at Yale.
And the project is
basically aiming to uplift
IntegrateNYC's youth developed frameworks
and to further contribute
their integration initiatives
at the university level.
And it's really about creating
like a networking level
across educational platforms
and really working to
move around resources
and build collaboration and content.
And if you guys are interested
in working that out,
please reach out to Joaquin.
I know we can also put
his email in the chat
but Integrate U was the next big thing.
- I'm gonna put Joaquin's
info in the chat.
Anything else folks here
that we'd like to plug?
All right, so what I'd like
to do in the way that we end
all of our meetings and
most intergenerational
organizing spaces is just an opportunity
for acknowledgement.
And so I can start with
acknowledging someone
and then have them pop
over to someone else.
I wanna first acknowledge Ayana.
Ayana, I loved your
comment about not being,
the risk of not being able
to take something back.
And what a risk that is for young people
who are navigating the media
and sharing their story.
So popcorning and affirmation to you
and asking you to pick it up
and affirms someone here.
And folks in the chat, if
you could affirm someone too
in the chat, that would be great.
- Yeah, I think I'm gonna affirm Aneth
'cause I felt like I really
resonated with her experience,
particularly the classroom
connections type of thing.
That's something I participated in
when I was in high school too.
And I found it really informative.
So it's always nice meeting
people with shared experiences.
And in general, I feel like
if she weren't participating,
it'd be really hard for me to
formulate my own responses.
And I feel like I took a lot
of inspiration from her responses.
So I'll popcorn Aneth next.
- Thank you so much, Ayana.
Shout out to you as well
and shout out to all the panelists.
'Cause like I was gonna, yeah,
I was gonna shout out Obrian,
acknowledge Obrian specifically
'cause I feel like you
made the most faces.
But everyone in this space
and all of your faces and reactions
like really, I'm such
a relationship scout.
So making, seeing that I
could like make y'all laugh
or like just get a reaction
is I really felt connected
in this spiritual setting.
So thank you for being in a space with me
and I'll pass it to Obrian.
- Oh, thank you.
I feel gassed.
I wanna acknowledge Alex.
I think that Alex did
with like power for the
conveyed, like every single idea.
When I was answering the
question, I was like, damn,
Alex like, perfectly said that
and I wish I would have went after.
'Cause then, maybe I could
have stolen a little bit
of information and inspiration from Alex.
So I'll popcorn it to Alex.
- Oh, thank you, Obrian.
Yeah, I guess, I guess my
affirmation goes to Matt.
Thank you for bringing
this kind of academic
perspective in all of this,
especially kind of helping
us uncover the untold stories
about school integration.
I think it's much, much needed, especially
when talking about how
kind of all of the issues
in American life is kinda highlighted
on the south when oftentimes,
it's really just looking
at yourself and your own privileges
and the regions that you are in.
That really kind of can
foster the most change.
So thank you for bringing that
perspective on this panel.
- Thanks, Alex.
And I wanna comment all
my fellow panelists.
I've been following the
work that Teens Take Charge
and IntegrateNYC, I've been
doing from far via social media
and online, so it's a pleasure
to have a chance to talk
with all of you.
I wanna thank Mira for
bringing everyone together
and Sarah for doing such
a great job of moderating.
I think that specific one.
Obrian, what you were saying
about sort of going to
school and to recognizing
sort of the access that
you had to certain things,
while also recognizing the
sort of vast inequalities
across the system really resonated with me
in just how we're always
kind of positioned
in these vast networks of
privilege and inequality
in ways that are fully under our control
but we try to navigate them
and change them for the better.
So Sarah, I'll popcorn back to you now.
- Thanks y'all.
And Mira, appreciate
you for creating a space
and that talked about being
brave and creating spaces
that haven't been done before.
And so building out spaces for
activists to create research
and create panels and to be honored
in the same spaces, folks
who are seen as scholars,
regardless of educational
access is important.
And so thank you for being
part of organizing this.
It took weeks, months.
So appreciate y'all.
So folks have a beautiful evening
and I ask everyone, all participants,
please attend, Teens Take
Charges summit this weekend,
contact IntegrateNYC with
a resource concept idea.
And please, please, please,
if you are a Yale student,
reach out Joaquin Soto
and be a part of bringing
this work to Yale University.
Have beautiful evening.